A while back, I was really angry at my little brother,...
...so I started yelling at him and then I went and pushed him really hard.
He got back up and started to cry and did nothing.
All he did was run towards me and then hug me.
When he hugged me, it awakened me and I felt so bad...
...when I realized what I was doing.
So I hugged him back tightly and I told him that I was really sorry.
He fought back with love, and it worked.
We're all built and ready to love.
If a baby could do it, so can we.
We need love.
Love isn't selfish.
It's for the other person.
It's what we do for someone that brings out their happiness,...
...in turn bringing out ours.
Love was always about the other person, not ourselves.